yo I hit I hit Jermaine with the 10,000
baby wipes son before we go why would
why did we talk about that before y'all
right you [ __ ] man look so I see you
depict you too I get an order of 10,000
about that around there's a lot of boxes
I guess UPS guy fed up we not picking up
the packages they just dropped them all
in once I'm in front of my [ __ ] house
which is why I sent you that picture
yeah it was one two three four five six
it's hidden boxes huge boxes of I don't
know what I'm what is this I thought it
was like I don't know what I don't know
where I thought it was but I thought was
a that was a mistake I open up the boxes
and each box had just just full of baby
wipes and on my eyes one okay the next
one hey Mike don't tell me full of baby
wipes yeah well you've done this before
- right I did three I hate Percy waited
for his birthday I hit Chelsea and I got
annoying as [ __ ] me my daughter just got
an argument the box comes my girl Burt
has OCD and when the box came she was
like who sent these I'm like I think it
was handle or she goes why would he do
that why'd he do that I think he's just
trying to help
oh I don't know Meghan with comedians I
don't like I say that we're comedians it
was what we do she don't understand why
we do that I was like baby just go out
I'll take care of the boxes and at that
point the baby started crying the baby
was crying and she was mad and I'm like
I'll fix this so let's take a picture
that's it the T those are the worst
nights of my life